hey guys it's Jenna here it's Chinese
New Year in the next couple of days and
I can't wait to go back to my hometown
to see all my friends and family members
that's going to be a lot of food house
visiting and lots of catching up to do
the kisses Chinese New Year I'm going to
share with you three of my favorite
Asian foods if you have been watching my
videos you will know that I like simple
very quick recipes healthy very
flavoursome and eating them will make
you feel good
so today's recipes do not require any
cooking you don't have to turn the stove
on and you don't need an oven you can
serve them for breakfast lunch dinner or
even as a snack so let's start by making
my childhood favorite Malaysian crispy
seaweed prepare if you ask any of my
friends if I can't decide on what I want
to have I will always resort to having
crispy sweet opium I just love the
combination of fresh sweet turnips with
seaweed so it is something I've eaten
from a very young age and I can
literally have this every single day and
I'm still not bored of it so to make one
serving of papaya what you'll need are
one large spring roll wrap one large
seaweed sheet about half a cup of sweet
turnip
shredded about quarter cup of carrots
shredded 2 tablespoons of a sweet corn
and just about 1 tablespoon of peanuts
crushed so on a flat surface place one
sheet of sea-weed and one sheet of
spring roll wrap on top of the seaweed
then arrange a generous amount of sweet
turnips shredded carrots a little bit of
sweet corn and crushed peanuts while
traditionally they would add a little
bit of mayonnaise I like to add a little
bit of garlic chili sauce you can choose
to top it up with any sources of your
choice then press a very firmly I roll
it up just like making a sushi roll
use a sharp knife and cut the spring
roll wrap into eight equal portions
serve fresh everybody you take your bite
into the sweetness and crunchiness of
the turnips carrots and corn combined
with the taste of seaweed it is just
absolutely delicious so if you're not a
vegan you can also choose to add meat
floss bonito flakes tuna eggs or crab
stick into the wrap H a serving is only
about 153 calories and I love to have
this for my breakfast it is best to be
eaten fresh so what you can do is prep
the vegetables ahead and only put them
together and roll them up when ready to
serve the next recipe is also another
favorite of mine when I visit a
Vietnamese or Thai restaurant cold glass
noodles salads I love glass noodles but
it is not commonly served so if you were
to dine in a Vietnamese or Thai
restaurant you might find this dish on
their menu so this is what it looks like
uncooked it is also known as moonbeam
noodles or cellophane noodles I really
enjoy the silky and fine texture of the
noodles so the noodles on their own do
not have a very prominent flavor but
rather it takes on the flavors of other
ingredients added into the dish and the
best part is it doesn't require any
cooking so to make this salad what
you'll need are five servings of glass
noodles about half a medium cabbage
shredded 2 medium carrots peeled and
shredded one red bell pepper diced one
Japanese cucumber thinly sliced half a
cup of fresh basil costly chopped half a
cup of fresh coriander costly chopped
one large spring onion thinly sliced and
about half a cup of unsalted peanuts
crushed and of course we'll also need to
make the spicy lime vinaigrette dressing
to go along with the salad so what
you'll need are three tablespoons of
fresh lime juice three tablespoons of
rice wine vinegar 1 tablespoon of soy
sauce 1/2 a tablespoon of sesame oil 1/2
a tbsp of olive oil
about half a tablespoon of maple syrup
one garlic clove minced and about half a
teaspoon of dried chili flakes so let's
go ahead and prep the noodles fill up a
large bowl with boiling hot water then
just soak the glass noodles for about 10
to 15 minutes until soft be sure to
cover the bowl now let's go ahead and
prep the salad dressing so in a small
bowl combine all the ingredients mix
well and set aside now let's go ahead
and prep the salad in a very large bowl
combine all the chopped up vegetables
and herbs stir in the dressing and toss
until well combined and allow the salad
mixture to sit for at least 10 minutes
for the vegetables to fully absorb the
flavors of the dressing let's check on
the glass noodles drain off the water
shake and they should be done to serve
place the glass noodles on a plate then
top it up with a generous amount of
salad
and finally just sprinkle with a little
bit of peanuts so what I really like
about this dish is that you can prep the
salad mixture ahead and in fact it would
taste better the next day the vegetables
will fully absorb the flavors of the
dressing and herbs to eat it just toss
the salad with the glass noodles the
noodles would take on the flavors of the
salad mixture and add a nice silky
texture to the dish this is a really
great work lunch you can just bring the
salad mixture and chill it in the fridge
at work and when you want to eat all you
have to do is soak the glass noodles in
hot boiling water and surf I also like
to serve this as a starter or snack
without the glass noodles so you have to
try it out and the final and easiest
dish is here yaku also known as Japanese
chilled tofu this dish is fresh and cold
and perfect for the hot summer which is
pretty much 24/7 all year round in
Malaysia it is ridiculous
the easy and quick to put together it
takes less than five minutes what you'll
need are one block of silken or soft
tofu drained and washed about one spring
onion thinly sliced one tablespoon of
grated ginger one to two tablespoons of
soy sauce and bonito flakes if you're a
vegan just omit the bonito flakes so
let's start by prepping the tofu place
it on a dish and carefully cut into six
equal slices then top it up with grated
ginger and a generous amount of spring
onions if you're not a vegan you can
also choose to top it up with the bonito
flakes which is how I like to have it
and finally drizzle some soy sauce over
the tofu and serve chilled see I told
you it is really quick and simple here
yaku is usually served as a side dish or
starter the tofu will take on the
flavors of the spring onions bonito
flakes and also ginger it is really
light and refreshing so guys if there
are days where you just feel lazy you
don't feel like cooking well make these
three Asian dishes they're are so simple
so quick to put together they are yummy
and I can assure you you will feel good
eating them so be sure to like and share
this video make them and let me know
which is your favorite in the comments
below
go see fat choy